demand for us bourbon and whiskey has
skyrocketed over the last decade gross
revenue for us distillers grew more than
50 percent between 2010 and 2015 and
while the goals is welcomed by the
industry it's fueling a brown liquor
drought Harlan Wheatley is the master
distiller at the Kentucky distillery
Buffalo Trace is there or isn't there a
shortage there seems to be an ongoing
debate about this there is a shortage
and it does depend a little bit on the
brands and which Bourbons you're talking
about but there's a shortage especially
in the premium and older aged Bourbons
why exactly what historically happened
to make that shortage happen and why it
does depend the brands what they happen
to own in the supply it's pretty simple
a few years ago for example for Buffalo
Trace eight years ago we simply just
didn't make enough and we estimated our
growth and each of our brands and over
time the demand has just simply outgrown
you know the supply and so you know the
products the problem is there's a lag
between production and when the product
is the market so if you're making an
8-year old product and you make it based
on a certain demand and it grows faster
than you planned you can't do anything
about it
haulin how are you addressing this
shortage for Buffalo Trace where we're
expanding so everything at the distiller
we've spent last year we spent over 70
million dollars expanding warehousing
and production and and we have plans
over the next ten years to continue that
expansion we're adding people and
continue to expand and and we're we're
gonna try to keep up with with a demand
should I be using this is an excuse
Holland and not that I need one to
stockpile bourbon well you know I do
tell people you should do a little bit
of homework if you have time so if you
if you have a local local store that you
typically shop at it's a good idea to
kind of get with them and understand
when they get deliveries and you know
what what brands will come in at certain
times that way you can make sure you
have enough to get you between
deliveries to get you through let me
through the show I need something
through the show oh I'm not going to
take any offense what
you can you can source bourbon elsewhere
right and make it your own or is that a
different type of strategy the good
thing about bourbon is it's something
that has to be made in the US so you
that you can go out and produce it
yourself there's a lot more producers
out there but you know if you're looking
at typical brands have been made for
centuries then you have to you know kind
of isolate those brands so is there a
timeframe on this shortage now what
point will you have enough again and
then is there the danger of oversupply
of having too much inventory there is
always that danger the one thing we do
know for sure is we will never be
correct either gonna under mate under
producer over produce but the timeline
for us we don't see it in any time in
the near future slowing down because the
demand is still strong and for us
globally is a new market for us as well
so where anywhere you can think of China
the European market Africa Australia all
right we better get our bottles of
bourbon trace well our Buffalo Trace
father around mark Barton our thanks to
Harlan Wheatley master distiller at
Buffalo Trace